good morning believe nation today's
message is get up over to you Bill
Clinton whatever it is doesn't work out
get up I lost two elections I was the
youngest former governor in American
history after the Reagan landslide I had
one guy appointed to the cabinet walk
across Main Street and Laura Rock to
avoid being seen shaking hands with me
for fear that the guy that beat me would
fire him that was a humbling experience
and I think you got to realize there's
no personal ambition you have which can
be extinguished by anybody else only you
by giving up your dreams can't
extinguish them and if it doesn't work
out exactly like you intended it'll
still take you someplace interesting and
you'll make a difference so my advice is
what George said don't be afraid to fail
but you probably will what are you
afraid to or not and it's scary you just
got to get up the world belongs to
tomorrow not yesterday don't give
anybody else permission to take your
life away just keep living and keep
giving and never make the perfect the
enemy the good never think that what I'm
doing is too little to make a difference
that's not true
that's not true do something every day
someday for all of us it'll be our last
day and what will matter with all the
steps we took along the way and what
they amounted to not the home run we hit
on day X your setback is only a failure
if you quit your setback is only a
failure if you quit if you look at the
most successful people in the world they
had tons of setbacks they had sent back
out their setback out their setback
after setback
then they started to win and then they
had more setbacks and then they won some
more that's part of the journey there's
nobody who wakes up is born and just
wins all the time
the people who have won the most also
had the most setbacks and this is across
entrepreneurship athletes singers you
always suck at the start you're always
gonna have setbacks and it's only really
a failure if you take that setback and
don't learn anything from it and quit if
you really want to do something and you
try it and you fail didn't work out and
then you stop and say that wasn't for me
I'm gonna move on something else if
that's your habit if that's your cycle
it's gonna repeat because the first time
you try anything it's not gonna work the
first time you try to skateboarding or
you tried to learn a language or you
tried asking a girl out like the first
time you try anything it's probably not
gonna work it's not gonna be great and
the more you do it the stronger your
muscle builds and the better you get at
it and so one of the keys to success in
any field is constant experimentation
constant trials constant errors and
constant getting back up if I look at
this YouTube channel is an example we
have tried more new series and failed at
them and left them then most people have
ever launched and we learn from those
and some of them we make better if you
look at even our top ten series look at
the very first one that we did and look
at where they're at now there's been a
lot of improvement the click quality is
better the editing is better the
transitions are better the intros are
better the bonuses are better everything
is better it's gotten better with more
experimentations and not every
experiment works and it's been a lot of
new series that we've launched that we
tried a couple times and it didn't work
and so we stopped them over onto
something else and learn from those if
you expect the first time you put
something out to be amazing if you're
making a YouTube channel and you expect
your first video to pop you're in for
really rude awakening it's not how the
world works and that's okay
except that get better move on and get
back up I'm remembered of the Thomas
Edison quote about how he didn't fail a
thousand times and making a light bulb
he just found 999 ways that it didn't
work and then that last one that he did
like would you stick with an idea
sometimes until you get it to work like
most people they'll try it once a lot of
people once in there they're out
I like we won't even try it a lot of
people just have the thought in their
head of trying it and because they feel
like they might fail they don't even do
it which is crazy and then you know half
the people may even do it and they try
it once and then it doesn't work out so
they fail and then some people may try
two or three times and it doesn't work
and they quit we're like would you be
willing the stick was up in a thousand
times and keep testing and keep trying
and keep improving where most people
would just see it as failure and they'll
stop and most people just quit too soon
and so just understand you know if you
really want something if you have a
drive a goal and ambition to create
something that maybe as brand-new has
never been done before maybe you're
following somebody else's footsteps it
has been done before but if you really
want to do something and you try it at
the start and it doesn't work out that's
just step one in your journey don't stop
on your path to doing something amazing
that you want to do just because you
didn't have initial success most people
quit way too soon most people quit
before they're gonna hit the finish line
where you could have had a great amazing
career but you stopped because you were
afraid and because you didn't have
initial success a setback is not a
failure unless you quit so the question
they today is I'm curious I want to know
when have you turned a setback into a
win talk to me about that process
talking to me about that experience
share down the comments below and we'll
join in the conversation I also want to
give a quick shout out to Andrew Schultz
and you thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word it
really really really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying it thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
they believe nation thank you so much
for watching if you want to learn more
about this subject get a little bit
deeper on it I'm gonna share some extra
bonus clips that I hope you'll enjoy
what has been the best advice you
received from your teacher or professor
Oh
I've gotten a lot of great advice from
teachers mentors professors throughout
the year so first of all you've got to
be open to taking some risks and not
being afraid to fail failure is the key
to success so when you get to college
you got to raise your hand you have to
be engaged
don't be the kid thinking oh I shouldn't
be here and maybe I'm not smart enough
and maybe you know no you are more than
capable of going to college being
successful and going on and doing
whatever you want in life
I sit here because I am you all there is
no difference between me and you
working-class kid growing up on the
south side of Chicago growing up with
doubts and fears just like all of you
all do I know exactly how you all are
feeling and kids out there who were
thinking maybe I'm not ready maybe I'm
not good enough maybe I can't afford it
but what teachers and mentors have told
me is that yes you can and you must so
get in there and be bold with your
intelligence raise your hand get support
when you need it
and know that we all got here because
somebody helped us listen to the people
who were successful in selling that
product I would learn new things from
different ones and new approaches and
that's very you must be a constant
student a lot of people are afraid to
try anything new because they are afraid
that they will be embarrassed until they
get good at it well one of my favorite
sayings is you know the most important
thing you can do is to understand that
anything worth doing is worth doing
poorly until you can learn to do it well
my first few sales calls were pathetic
but I knew it was worth doing so I kept
after it you know my first few speeches
were in this answer but I believed that
I could develop into that
so I kept added unto I could do it
effectively and all skills are exactly
the same way no running back that sets
the records ever we set a record the
first time he picked up a football and
you can go right down the line with that
so if it's worth doing and you believe
in it go ahead and fail and the more
times you fail the closer you get into
success because you should be learning
on every simple thing that you do
because I knew that they would come one
day I'll be standing before him who for
children and tell them because of what
happens to your life
we both of the adversity both of the
opposition regardless the trial
tribulation nothing can stop you the
only thing that can stop you is you know
situation no circles there's no piece of
that mercy can define the right never
either circumstance define you see I've
done something about you I can speak
from a certain place I know something
about you without even know with you I
know what they wanted to come into this
pool and do what I have to do you can do
it I don't want to go into a classroom
and this free means you can do it I
don't you want to go to Pilate I know
that you can become whatever it is that
you want to become but it's like that
quote you can lead a horse to water but
you can't make them drink you see I can
tell you all the right things like to
stand up here and say a presentation but
if you walked out of these doors and you
don't apply to your life what Goodwin
you see I'm not so concerned with you
know you haven't changed you have been
most unconcerned with the process
because a lot of people are surprised
but not many people want the process a
lot of people have been well blend but
few people have the will to prepare to
live the processes were important to the
price the process is more important in
the body and what the process is the
process is coming into this building
they activate even everything you've got
individual that you need to become in
order to make those things happen you
know the reason you've said no the
reason we set goals and the reason women
have dreams it's not for the output the
reason you said those are the reason you
have dreams is to become the person that
you need to become in order to make them
manifest in the light you see how people
the road to success it's currently under
construction with plenty of potholes of
linear speed but with plenty of Nick
tours with plenty of parking spots to
give up but just as if they were in a
car with your mother you find a way to
get over that speed bump we finally get
around that potholes you're kind of way
to get to that each the only thing about
right that destination maybe that goal
was a dream or whatever it is that you
aspire to do with your life the one
thing that can tell you right now man
I'm not anything special but the one
thing I can guarantee you people and
imma leave you with this if you don't
give up if you don't stop if you don't
give it nothing will defeat you nothing
will come for you nothing will stop
never give up never stop never doubt
yourself good ways to me there's always
hope there's always somebody inside you
guys closer than anything that like
you're wet